first question Doug on the right side
fourth row yeah NIC Doug Smith the
Toronto Star that third quarter when you
sort of took control of the game he went
back to Fred and got big minutes out of
surge is that what your team does you
find the way to get the right guy in the
right spot well we you know we had a big
problem with the third quarter in Game
two Doug so we we you know had to make
some adjustment there to try to combat
the way they come out of the half you
know they've been historically really
good at that and you know we made the
decision to put Fred in in Game three
and then Game four again tonight so and
mostly it's it's four to try to keep our
pace of our offense going gives us you
know two point guards out there that can
push the ball get it in and get it going
and and it kind of paid off I know
quiets two big threes to start the half
really I thought changed the whole feel
of everybody I just thought everybody
was like okay man we know we're here
let's go and we just kind of kept kept
going from those two threes oh yeah yeah
you know you know he's once he once he
gets into the series which he did in
Game three you know with the block shots
and the rebounding and stuff he seems to
stay in the series and he was he was
great tonight man he was and it's kind
of all he usually gives you all of it
once he starts blocking a couple shots
and the offense comes and the rebounding
comes and a putback here and there and
even is even as jump shot seems to come
you know once he gets into the game
defensively with a block shot or to them
Tim in the back left Nick Tim Reynolds
with the AP kawaii demeanor is obviously
well chronicled how he's pretty much
unflappable in any situation has your
team taking its cues from him or do you
have a bunch of guys who in a lot of
ways or just just happen to be like him
in that they don't get rattled they
don't seem to be too too shaken in any
moment I mean I think I think we
certainly I think most teams will take
cues from their leaders or their star
players so I think I think that that
spreads
a little bit but I also think he got you
know marks pretty steady out there and a
high IQ level pretty level-headed guy it
doesn't show much emotion Danny comes
and goes a little bit I guess but you
know and you know I think like - I think
a lot of that veteran stuff it's you
know Kyle's been great with his
emotional makeup the season and Pascal
for being a young guys probably taken
the cues from those older guys and
Freddie Freddie's pretty pretty steady -
Robert middle-right Robert Lata BSO um
even though these were two road games so
it was a strong contingent of raptors
fans that were in attendance very vocal
you know what does that mean to your
team to see fans travel all the way from
Toronto to here to a tough place to play
an Oracle you hear them chanting you
know MVP for Kauai and every time that
you guys make a good play or shot you
know really a very vocal you guys hear
that and you know you feel about that
yeah it's it's awesome
first of all right I think I think we
travel our fans travel really well in
the regular season we get this a lot on
the road it's really amazing you know
it's it's Canada's team and in Canadians
from all over the country are traveling
down and making plans when we play in
Florida or California or any of the you
know Detroit especially
these gays cuz I don't think it's that
easy to get tickets to these games so
our fans are working extra hard and be
an extra vocal and we appreciate that
second row and you're right coach Nick
nurse Christa Creek USA today just
wanted to kind of get your nurse exactly
thank you just wanted to get your
thoughts just on the chess match coach
Kerr is sort of known to make
adjustments throughout the series in his
history but it seems like you're kind of
getting the best of him a tad do you
relish that chess match back and forth I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that at all I'm
just listen I think that we have to go
out there we don't know who's available
who's playing and we you know we've
taken the stance of just whoever's out
there we got to figure it out and and we
try to change the the whose garden who a
little bit here and there just because
there's so many different guys in or now
you know they start somebody different
every night it seems like I don't I
don't know about any other adjustments
or any of that stuff that but we're
getting the better of we're just we're
just our guys are playing really hard
and and so far and especially the last
couple games that you know we've been
fortunate that it's come out our way how
do you compare this team to the 2014
Spurs in the finals in terms of
defensively it seems like there's a lot
of similarities there yeah I don't
remember much about those guys other
than they were really good and I don't
know I'm not very good at comparing
teams or players from from years gone by
but this team I thought we played really
tough tonight we were we were taking a
lot of punches early and we just kept
standing in there and in playing and
then we you know then we were able to
kind of exert our will in the second
half I guess there's probably similar to
what they did but I don't really
remember Eric in the back right ear
Kareem the athletic Pascal at a really
rough offensive start to the game and he
sort of just stayed with it and was even
able to hit that final 16 footer that
they sort of left
for him do you think as the playoffs
have progressed he sort of figured out
how to stay in games better or is that
bit in him all along well it's just in
prayer yeah I mean he obviously it was
kind of his game was kind of typical of
the game right he was he was getting
doubled early which was an adjustment by
them and then they were also taken the
easy well the quick pass back right out
where it came from they were they were
doubling and then denying Kyle and we
weren't doing a very good job of giving
him an outlet so he was pretty rattled
early alright and that's that's part of
what you do to double-team guys is to
try to rattle them in general so for him
to hang in there and keep finding some
moments to to play was good I think he
made a bunch of free throws tonight -
didn't he 7 for 8 from the line I
thought he got again I always say when
he's playing good he has great composure
he gets in there he gets to 2 feet he
gets on balance he'll wait for the angle
or a pump fake or whatever and I thought
he did a better job of waiting for his
moment in the second half mark and then
Steve last two questions nick mark
Schwartz ESPN we hear a lot about Golden
State's championship pedigree tonight I
think we saw Kawhi Leonard's
championship pedigree what has his
pedigree done to help you to help put
you in the situation in this series well
I mean obviously he's playing great
right and he's uh he's lifted us a lot
of times with with big buckets or runs
of buckets or just that settling bucket
when the place is going crazy and he'll
calmly sink one you know to kind of
quiet the crowd but I think you know
more than anything you know just I think
again your team's vision of who they can
become eventually changes and and I say
that about Marc Gasol too and we and I
say that about Marc Gasol too when we
got him I think you know we started
passing the ball or assists started
going way up we became the number one
three-point shooting team in the league
because of the extra passes and the
contagious passing etc and I think our
team again thought their sense of who
they thought they could become went up
Steve back right next eve Simmons
Toronto Sun all playoffs long we've been
hearing from the players one day at a
time one game at a time one win at a
time all the way through one to go now
how do you keep on that mental thing
with so much excitement going on yeah I
mean I think it's I think it's difficult
Steve I mean you know we're gonna get
back there and as you know they're gonna
be going crazy in Toronto and you know
my message to them is is is we've never
really talked about the series score
can't let people take you someplace you
aren't yet alright and and we know this
is a great team and we know how hard we
have to play to beat them you know home
or away we know how hard we have to play
and just just focus in on trying to be
the hardest working team on the floor if
we do that then we'll give ourselves a
chance to win and and go from there
Thank You coach yep Steve Kerr we'll be
right in